first of all
i uh want to say welcome uh
to everyone to uh for
attending our follow-up salon
after uh carl rovelli's excellent talk
yesterday
uh discussing the intricacies
of causes and effects and so today we're
going to have
a sort of a moderated discussion with
the open q a at the end of it
and it is my absolute pleasure to
introduce to you uh the interlocutor for
today and
that is eric winsberg who is
a philosopher of science and works on
philosophy of
physics a lot and has worked in
particular
on models inferences
drawing inferences from modeling and
conceptual frameworks
he's an expert and he's looked at many
kinds of models
so he's extremely well known for his
work on
the nature of simulations and numerical
simulations
with applications particularly to one of
the most
vexing problems of our times
which is the climate problem so the
modeling of climate
and what the issues are with
modeling a complex system like that
which is a non-linear complex system
so that is sort of his expertise and in
general as i mentioned he looks at
conceptual frameworks and currently he
is looking at uh kobit 19.
and isn't that right eric so you're yeah
i've been looking at some of the
modeling stuff with kelly knight
yeah uh so and of course uh
carlo rovelli needs no introduction a
philosopher
of physics physicist
and an acclaimed writer
who writes and is invested deeply in
sort of the public understanding
of science so i'm absolutely delighted
to give the floor over to the two of you
so eric did you um you had a few slides
with which
yeah i thought i would just kind of um
review some of the key points of the
talk
and along the way uh raise where i
thought the
most interesting points for discussing
some questions were kind of integrate
some of the questions that people asked
yesterday
and sort of maybe integrate them with my
way of thinking about them rephrase them
in my way of thinking about them
okay so let me share my uh my powerpoint
here
um okay
great so this is just uh carla's title
what is the cause and why does it happen
before the effect
um and uh so just to kind of uh remind
people of what the basic situation is
here right
um the laws of physics don't seem to
privilege a basic direction in time
but um they're sort of three at least
three maybe four
key aspects of ordinary experience uh
that do seem to privilege a direction of
time
one is what you might just think of as
the ordinary physical asymmetry in time
right
you know we see ice melting in our
cocktail glass
and the water uh cooling as that happens
we don't see the water spontaneously
cool uh warming and ejecting ice cubes
eggs break but they don't
unbreak right so we just see there are
lots of phenomena that we see in the
world
that are time asymmetric uh the second
one is that i know more a lot more about
the past thank you about the future and
i know it with greater ease
if i want to know what the weather in
tampa was on february 28
1954 i can look at an old edition of the
tampa times but if i want to know
what it's going to be february 28 2021 i
need to make a forecast using
basic physics and if i want to know what
it's going to be february 28
2054 i'm just out of luck there's no way
i'm gonna know that
okay um the third and i we're gonna try
to
i'm gonna try to say more carefully what
this means i think this one's hard to
state
i can influence the future but not the
past that's kind of the key
thing that that carlo's talk was about
but as i
want to kind of point out it's not
exactly clear what we mean when we say
that
and then there's actually kind of a
fourth asymmetry that people sometimes
talk about and that's that
i sometimes seem to care more about my
future self than my past self
if you ask people would you rather you
know would you rather have had a
headache yesterday
of that have one tomorrow most people
would say yes i'd rather have it out of
the way i'd rather have the headache
yesterday than tomorrow
it's better to have bad things be in the
past and it's better to have good things
in the future
so i seem to care more about my future
self than my past self
so those are kind of four features of
ordinary experience they're time
asymmetric
and all of them you know put a little
bit of a puzzle given that the laws of
physics themselves are time asymmetric
okay so what do we mean when we say that
the laws of physics are
are times symmetric well one way to
think about it is by thinking about
physics as describing as living in kind
of a state space
so the easiest way to think about this
is if you just and everything i'm going
to say this is going to i'm going to
assume kind of
a really simple classical physics
picture of the world but
nothing really hinges on that it just
kind of makes it a little bit simpler
so if you think of you know if you think
of a box of gas with a bunch of
particles bouncing around
you can sort of mathematically represent
that
um if there's you know n particles
bouncing around and each particle has
three direct three three numbers that
pick at its position
and three numbers that pick out its
velocity then a six to the n dimensional
space
kind of one point in that completely
describes right
completely describes that system and
what it is to say that the laws of
physics
are time symmetric is to say that what
the laws really do
is they pick out allowable paths through
that space base
and to say that they're time symmetric
it's just to say that
anytime the laws allow a path going this
way
they allow the time they allow that same
pathway in the opposite direction
there's some there's some slight and
felicity's in that but none that really
matter
right okay so um so
as as carlo pointed out this has just
been a feature
of physical laws pretty much since
newton we've had lots of different
theories of what the physical world
is like they all seem to have this
feature they all seem to be
time symmetric they all seem to say if
something can happen
at the microscopic level then it's time
reverse can happen
that just seems to be that just seems to
be kind of a non-starter
to deny that when for the last you know
400 years
as we've been coming up with theories of
physics
okay and but again right can i do this
yeah so we know right that our ordinary
experience
um right it's just a little youtube
video i found yesterday right this is
this is the ad for a company that allows
you to reverse your video
and when we see things happening right
backwards
they strike us as strange right that's
just not
that's just we immediately recognize
that as something that does not
happen in our ordinary experience okay
um uh so um so where does that come from
right we we know it can't come from the
laws of physics
so if it comes from physics it's got to
come from somewhere else
and the answer is usually that it comes
from something to do
with the initial conditions right
because that's all there is that's all
physics has it has laws
and it has initial conditions and once
you give the logic the expeditions
physics basically says you've picked out
the whole world for me
okay but but there's kind of a third
thing that we need
um and this carlo mentioned this a lot
yesterday that's this idea that we need
a macro partition that is we need a way
of
carving up the possible way the world
could be
at the microscopic level into ways that
are discernible to us
right so that obviously there's lots you
could make very small changes
in the microscopic physics of the world
that i'm looking at right now and i
wouldn't notice them
so if you kind of carve the world up
into the little bits of
microscopic ways the world could be um
and uh then put them into little bundles
of ones that are indiscernible to me
you get this mic you get this macro
partition
and if it turns out right that the laws
of physics
basically bang you around in here as a
kind of more or less random walk
and the macro in the macro partition
the initial state that the universe
started in is a very very small one
then that kind of maybe can explain why
right as the laws of physics bat us
around in this
in this macro partition we go from
smaller ones to bigger ones
and our brains are wired right when we
see the egg
reassembling itself our brains are
saying wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute you've moved from
a big area in the macro pick partition
to a small volume sorry volume in the
macro partition
and that ain't right right and that
strikes us as bizarre and we think
that's weird
and it's not part of our ordinary
experience but
right these two things together write
these three things together right
um some laws of physics
an initial condition that we start in in
this macro partition
hopefully can explain right and this i
think is pretty uncontroversial
that can explain why eggs break but they
don't reassemble
why ice melts but it doesn't
spontaneously form etc
okay good so that explains eggs but what
about
what about the weather report why why do
we have records of the past
um but not records of the future and i
used to be kind of
a little bit of a skeptic about whether
um
this story could work but it's actually
carlo's paper that i read just a few
months ago i forget what the title is
the one it's the one we read it with the
san diego reading group
it's a really really nice paper i think
he really nicely explains
how the how the statistical mechanical
symmetry i just talked about
gives you the temporal asymmetry of
records and the idea is just this
right that like if you have nice
smooth you know sort of um low
entropy devices kind of sitting here
right like a nice calm pond
and you throw some other sort of you
know
low entropy thing and they collide with
each other
you then you get right you get a
disturbance in that they kind of can
persist for a while
and usually just i'm not doing this
justice but he's a really nice paper i
think
he lays out all the details of this in a
way that i found that i actually found
rather
convincing even though i sort of maybe
previously been a little bit of a
skeptic of this
okay so so that's how we get so that's
how we get
um out of just the asymmetry in the
initial conditions
plus this macro prediction that's how we
get maybe
maybe and i've become more and more
convinced of this that's how we get um
the existence of records about the past
but no records of the future
okay so um so that's that seems so that
seems nice right even though the laws of
physics are time reversible
a nice core screening on the initial
conditions
would explain why we have records in the
past but not the future
okay but notice right notice if we want
both of these things
either one of them really right if we
want to explain why eggs don't unbreak
and we want to explain why their records
we need not just the right laws on the
right course frame we need a harmony
between
the dynamical laws and the course frame
that does all the work right
some some laws on initial conditions
with different course trainings won't
prevent eggs from unbreaking
and some core screenings won't prevent
experiment breaking with different laws
okay um and fundamental physics
is completely ignorant of the core
screening right the course training is
not a feature
of fundamental physics so where so where
does the core screening come from
well it comes from us right and so here
i want to remind people of a of a
question that that brian campbell smith
asked yesterday
he asked right i hear you saying that
biology and culture require low entropy
macro variables
this is how why where we developed could
it be instead that we are more um
responsible for the low entropy
microscopic proxies than we use as a
consequence
could it we could it be that we humans
correspond the world
world in ways that parcel up in low
entropy ways
and um and and carlo's answer was well
yes
both right and we do correspond it but
not
not by choice right it's not a choice of
ours to correspond it
it's something about our our
the basic way that we're put together
right i mean here's my way of thinking
about it right
it's hard to imagine i would think
creatures
whose stabilizing properties and
information
processing abilities and reproductive
abilities etc
are realized right with the kind of
biochemistry and the kind of
neurophysics and the kind of you know
the basic kind of way in which we're
engineered
right it's hard to imagine creatures
like us who didn't have our core
straining
okay um uh so
if the direction of time is tied to uh
is tied to
um is tied to causation and causation is
tied to agency
um we might want to ask what is required
for agency
and is agency fundamentally tied to our
course grading
and there are a couple of questions we
could ask here that i think are really
interesting one is like
you know could there be agents whose
core straining is such that what we call
the final state of the universe
is very low entropy to them and
therefore are kind of zooming by us in
the opposite causal direction
of course we would never see these guys
right but is that possible
right um or or is it just impossible to
imagine
creatures who do anything remotely like
information processing
and reproduction and whatever else we
would think would make them preachers
um uh without having the same course
grading as us
that's i think something that's sort of
probably
hard to answer but been interesting to
speculate about
and this is i think another question
that that i was wondering about
during carlo's talk yesterday so
it's really i've been i thought about
this question of where coarse graining
comes from for a long time
and there's sort of two different ways
of thinking about it right what is it
about
us that that core strength so if you if
you take like an introductory
statistical mechanics book right it'll
say what the course straining is is it
you know say something like
it's a core screening of the universe
into states that
are equal with respect to certain
microscopic
variables like and usually they launch
things like temperature
pressure magnetization things like that
those are usually the macroscopic
variables that we think of as
horse training when we're doing physics
rather than like philosophy or whatever
um so one thing i've always wondered
about is
does my core screening come from my
observational capacities
or does it come from my interventional
capacities
or is it some complicated mixture of the
two
and if it fundamentally involves my
interventional capacities
is there something a little bit circular
about the whole story now so
you know i tend to think of like well
what what what
what the history of statistical
mechanics is right it starts with
thermodynamics
and thermodynamics was a control theory
thermodynamics was the theory which said
here are the things that you if you want
to be an engineer that's building steam
engines
here are the things you can do here are
the kinds of interventions that you can
make in the world
and here are the ones that are
impossible right
but they're impossible not because
they're not because microphysics forbids
them
they're impossible because of the kind
of creature that you are with with big
fat fingers right um and
right so it's almost sometimes i think
like
the core screening comes not just from
what i can discern observationally
but what causal handles i have on the
world
um and if that's right i my spider sense
starts to tingle now
that maybe something circular is going
on here and i'm not really sure if i
think that or not but i'd like to
explore that idea like at least hear
carlo's
story about why i shouldn't be a worry
okay
um eric i have a quick question yes
please
in this particular case are you i mean
is this a claim
that evolution maybe selects for this
so there's like a thermodynamic
selection i mean
are you well the idea is the idea is
this
this goes back to let's go back back to
maxwell's demon right
so maxwell uh james cook maxwell's
one of the founders of cisco mechanics
pointed out right
that if you had a little guy who was
small enough
that he could see every little bouncing
particle in a box of gas and you could
open and close a shutter
right right in response to them he could
cause anti-thermodynamic behavior to
happen
okay so the fact that we can't bring
about
thermal anti-thermodynamic behavior has
to do with the difference between
us and maxwell's demon and that
difference is
something like that my fingers are too
fat right i can't operate little
shutters that small fast enough
yes fast enough quickly enough
responsively enough to micro conditions
what my interventions on the world are
they're brooder and coarser than that
and that's kind of what picks out the
core screening and is it kind of
it you know carly used this expression
subtle dance between two things a lot
yesterday
and i i feel like there's there's
something going on here in the macra
partition
which is people often talk about it
being having to do with their
observational capacities
but i think it's kind of the result of a
subtle dance between our observational
and our interventional capacities
um and i i i kind of like to see if we
can talk about that a little bit at some
point today because i think it's kind of
interesting
okay another thing that i kind of would
sort of notice in the talk yesterday
is that um carly you used a couple of
different
quite different characterizations of
agency
um early in the talk you talked about
agency as just kind of
anything counts as an agent if i can
bracket it off
and it sort of affects what's an
otherwise closed system
so if i can divide the universe into two
halves and consider one half of it
closed
and then something comes from over in
this half and comes in and bounces it
like a meteorite or something like that
that can count as agency
but i i guess i i feel like that's not
quite right and i feel like later in the
talk you said things that i'm that i
think are
are more right about what agencies
agents are the kinds of people
sorry agents are the kinds of entities
that um collect information
deliberate about what they want the
future to be like
and um uh you know
move themselves around in the world some
way or other
so as to bring about things that they
prefer
right so there's intentionality there's
some intentionality
there's some information processing
there's some
uh deliberation uh there's
there's stuff like that so and and we're
only
thinking about why i don't think that
the first characterization of agency
works is
um we do talk about sort of you know
meteorites coming in and causing craters
we do this but i think that's parasitic
on
the causal ordering that we've already
imposed on the world that comes from our
deliberation agency
i don't think if if you know if
microscopic laplacian demons
came to our world and there were no
people in it they wouldn't think that
incoming meteorites and outgoing
volcanic eruptions were interestingly
different
there'd be no asymmetry there the
asymmetry i think only comes when
we have deliberative agents because of
the causal asymmetry
right i think only happens when we have
deliberate agents
or if not i'd kind of like to hear more
about why i shouldn't think that because
that's my that's my inclination uh
okay so so so what is agency
right to me agency is fundamentally tied
to deliberation
which means it's tied to information
gathering information
processing it's tied to preferences
and it's tied to integrating all those
abilities so as to bring about
preferences
okay so so when i talked about the third
asymmetry at the beginning i said it's
that we can
it's that we can change the future but
not the past but that's of course
wrong right we've known sort of since
david hume
right that well we have to understand
agency
um in harmony with determinism right
we have to understand that there's it's
possible to have a gentile beings in a
deterministic world and in the
deterministic world
i can't change the future anymore that i
can change the past
but i still deliberate about it and it's
a puzzling fact
it's a puzzling fact but it's one you
have to swallow right
so it's not it's not that causes
proceed effects that's a reasonable
first pass
what the asymmetry is but i don't think
it's exactly what the asymmetry is
i think the asymmetry is that it's not
that we can influence the future but not
the past
right so the first the problem with the
first characterization is it's
non-agential
and there's no non-agential um
characterization of the third asymmetry
the problem with the second
characterization is it doesn't
it doesn't um respect you know the
insights of compatibilism
that we have to understand deliberation
alongside determinism
right so i think i think the real third
asymmetry is this it's that we
on pain of insanity right on pain of
insanity
we deliberate about how we want to make
the world be in the future
we do not deliberate about how we want
the world to be in the past
when we make decisions okay
if someone if you saw someone standing
in a lever
trying to decide whether to put the
lever to the right or to the left
and you said what are you doing what are
you trying to figure out
what's what are you deciding on the
basis of and the person said i want the
world to be in such and such a way in
the future and i'm trying to figure out
which side this lever goes is more
likely to bring about the future than i
want
we'd say yeah that's cool that's a
normal thing you're a normal person
if they said that about the past we call
them men with white coats
right why that's i think that's the
asymmetry this is what hugh price is
called
the the the um temporal asymmetry of
disjunctive deliberation
nice fancy word for that okay um
so so agency right i'm putting up the
trolley probably not because i'm gonna
start talking about ethics right
but here's you know here's the famous
fill up a foot trolley problem
um should i push the fat man in front of
the trolley to save the five people
right that's a perfectly sensible
question
but should i push the fat man on the
trolley so to prevent
so maybe you know maybe you tell me hey
you know what eric someone is predicting
whether you're going to push the fat man
onto the tracks
and if he predicts that you're gonna
push him on the tracks he's gonna kill
five people
you just you you just your mind recoils
at this whole scenario and you end up in
newcomers paradox and you end up in all
kinds of
strange things because we just think
it's absurd
to when when we're thinking of ourselves
as agents when we're deliberating
about what actions to take we think it's
absurd
to worry about how they're going to make
the past be
okay now it's
absolutely right it's absolutely right
that you can solve this problem this
problem goes away
this problem stops being a problem it
stops being a puzzle
if you can explain the sense in which
the future is open and the past is
closed
because if the past is closed and of
course i don't deliberate about how to
change it
okay but here's the here's the sixty
four dollar thousand sixty four thousand
dollar
question i think about yesterday's talk
does the existence of records
sufficiently close the past and open the
future
to explain the sense and why it's insane
to deliberate about changing the past
and carl i see carlos shaking his head
which which is which which worries me
which worries me because i think that's
what we need
if we really want to understand if we
really want to solve this the main
a puzzle of asymmetry about causation
it's this
why do i not deliberate about how i want
the past to be
and um right uh so
does the existence of record sorry as
basically doing the slide right does the
existence of records secure the relevant
notions of the past being
the past and future being respectively
closed and open
okay um and there were i think a couple
of questions from the audience yesterday
that were pressing on this so peter
morgan asked
right um my zoom thing gets up in the
way here we go
the past is only fixed and so far as
traces persist
is it only the creation of traces is
relatively fast
the decay of traces is slower that if we
burn evidence is gone right so
so so the worry here is right that there
are lots of things about the past
right that we don't have traces of
yeah there's a lot about the past that's
open why don't i deliberate about how to
make that different
exactly right um and and so uh
parikh also asked right if two people
are observing the same traces
might make different inferences about
the past we assume that one is right and
the other is wrong
okay but if the if the fact about if
the closed-ness of the past is about the
inferences i can make from records
something weird is going on right that's
a that's a
shaky notion of clothes it's a very
epistemic notion
of the past being closed and it might be
closed for me and open for you
so you might think it's insane for me to
deliberate how the past gives me because
you believe
right like maybe i'm trying to kill baby
hitler
and you think you have a picture of baby
hitler so you think i'm insane
and i say no that picture of baby
hitler's blurry i think maybe the past
about whether there's a baby hitler is
still open or not
i mean that seems like a weird that
seems like a weird
thing for the insanity of me trying to
bring it about not by time travel
but just by by just by intervening on
the present
trying to kill baby hitler the whether
that's insane or not
depending on whether the picture of baby
hitler is blurry or not
um seems weird
uh okay um i think i'm getting close to
the end
um yeah so the existence of records
doesn't seem like it's enough to prevent
me from deliberating about how i want
the past to be
um both because records are limited uh
and because records
are uncertain okay
so thanks carla thanks for your talk
yesterday super interesting
super thought-provoking um those are
those are some of my
those are some of my questions uh thank
you eric that was uh
fantastic love your slides wonderful
and i think uh we are waiting to hear
back
from carlo about i think a lot of um
intriguing questions that um you have
raised and i think some of these
questions
are quite profound i have to say so
i'm really looking forward to what uh
carlo has to respond
um thank you thank you eric um
i have been um taking notice no
notes furiously while you were talking
um
let me anticipate a couple of things
before trying to answer first of all
very happy
of of what you um have done
uh these are subtle issues of course
um and i often find myself
uh discussing with people that
uh have a lot of different assumptions
and uh it's uh it's it's difficult to
sort of start organizing
the common ground uh that's not
the case at all in in what i heard you
uh
saying now i mean i know a little bit of
your work
well i think i i i agree with everything
you say
um i mean we are on the same ground uh
we agree on the problems we agree on the
situation
um so i'm entirely with you with uh with
everything
and you have raised two
problems um in fact uh
not really to challenges but to to point
in which you say wait there is a
they seem to be missing something here
uh
and they're both crucial um
i think i have some understanding about
both and i'm happy to try
it on you and i think we do have
sufficient ground
maybe not in a half an hour if we had a
couple of days and a into armchairs
maybe a blackboard i think we could uh
we could totally uh communicate on that
let me try
um and i'm a little hesitant of doing
both because the second is more
interesting yeah i think the second is
definitely more interesting yeah
yeah but let me let me let me say
something about the first
and then you tell me if you want to uh
stay on that
on on on the first so the first one
um was about a possible singularity
in uh uh let me put it uh in
in in a bit over sketchy matter
manner in in the definition of
thermodynamics definition of microscopic
quantities what what are the microscopic
quantities
uh that somehow in terms of which we
make sense of
reversibility and irreversibility and i
am 100
with you that uh the clarity
in about thermodynamics is is about how
we manipulate things and uh um in spite
of uh
i'm 100 with you that in spite of the
huge literature of that diverse position
maxwell had it clear uh namely
uh thermodynamics is about a
thermodynamical system
on which we do something and we have a
finite number of things we're doing
and the terminology will tell us what
happened if i do this it would happen if
i do that
there's a notion of manipulability
which is the one that defines the
constraining
because the the microscopic quantities
are the ones on which i
intervene or not this
brings complete clarity to the structure
of thermodynamic itself
what is missing is not anything related
to myself what is missing is that all
right so who is the manipulator
and what uh how do we think in terms of
manipulator
if we want to make a step further and
say well i'm a naturalist i don't think
there are you know
demon's sign nature or us outside nature
but the natural systems that are us
manipulating
and demons are natural systems and
nowadays in laboratories you can do
little demon macro demon things with
them with
molecules and and these are network
systems
so then um one possibility
is just to take the notion of
manipulation as
primitive or another is try to see how
it concretely
it's uh it's uh realized
in in by by by by the manipulator as a
physical system
and i think that here
there is a step that we can make and
i've been insisting on that step
namely we don't need manipulation we
we may have a simpler um
a more wider way of saying exactly the
same thing namely instead
of thinking thermodynamics if i do this
that's what happened
we can see and it's equally if there is
an
external system that happened to
interact in this way
that's what's going to happen
if so what determines the the cost
screening
it's an actual uh
dynamical interaction between the system
and
and the manipulator the observer in
other words
as a naturalist like i i want to think
of both of them as described in physical
terms and again as you did forget
quantum mechanics everything that's just
classic
so if you want there is a hamiltonian
the hamiltonian it has an interaction
terms
this interaction term is an interaction
with some variables
of the system not all of them good
it is that hamiltonian picks up some
variables
and to the extent in which i'm
describing the interaction of the system
with something else the the the observer
the demon that only interact with that
hamiltonian with that variable
what happens is well described by the
thermodynamics with those those costs
grading
so i've no yeah that seems that seems
good i mean
you can just describe what what what is
the coupling between me
exactly another system then you don't
really have to think that much about
what my interventions are
because obviously my interventions are
going to be parasitic on what my cup
lengths are
exactly and this this allows uh so the
price of this
is that we don't have a a in a priority
that's a thermodynamic dependent on
which system is interacting out
fine i buy that and i don't think at
this point there is any circularity
that's that's that's that's that's what
satisfies me
that's your first question yeah okay
let's move on yeah let's move let's
i do think the second question is
which is the interesting one is about
agency and the liberation
and look
i i follow carefully what you're saying
and uh
agree with everything at some point you
say wait a minute
um what do you mean by agent
and at this point uh
we don't want to go into a an issue
of names of course um
it is a fact that we use agent in a
different to indicate different things
and uh uh there is is
so we can say agent one agent two agency
whatever i mean
we can do different names to two things
so there's one definition of agent
which is too wild it's not the one you
like but it's
it can be found in in the literature
which is very weak um uh i'm going to
the next one i'm going to the other one
in a moment
but the weak one is simply um
it depends on uh
uh on at its turn it depends on an
approximate description of the situation
so it
depends on certain number of variables
which are related by some relations
between
between them uh for instance macroscopic
for instance the solar system dynamics
newtonian dynamics
and i want to call agents everything
which is exogenous to that
and interact with that at some time at
some point so just really quick right i
mean
you're absolutely right nothing nothing
hangs on what the
you know dictionary definition of agent
is or anything like that
but but what what hangs on is which
which which notion of the agency
underpins a temporal asymmetry right
yeah yeah
it's clear and then you're saying
wait a minute uh when we when we talk
about
agency that you know when when temporal
symmetry comes in
there's more there's a notion of
deliberation okay
now there's no doubt that there are very
special agents that deliberate
okay um even those are very different
kinds
because the thermostat of my
apartment uh sits quite
many of the characterization of the
liberator that you gave
uh the rover which is on mars
uh which independently decides that
you know uh there is a sandstorm
arriving so it shuts it
it set down it has a purpose which is to
preserve itself
which is written in its software so it's
a deliberator in
in in some sense um
why and in fact the rather on march is a
good example because uh
sometimes it decides by itself sometimes
it doesn't
because we caught we we we govern it
from uh
and we use this language regularly okay
take away its freedom and now we control
it
no let it let it decide by itself okay
we do understand exactly the physics of
the rover on mars
we pretend to understand be able to
understand that
we might be uh and this is a huge kind
of warmth but
i think we might take the stance that uh
we could use exactly the same logic for
understanding humans
namely a lot of things happening in
our mind
some of this we describe as deliberation
the same ones as
we use deliberation now
let me get let me zoom in to the point
um
what is it in the physics
of those systems that we call uh
uh agent that correct that
specifically uh has to do with the
difference between the past and the
future
and i think is not uh it's nothing to do
directly with traces it's a different
story
and it is the fact that it's the same
logic as it traces but it's a very
different story
so is the fact that that um
there is a system that has a
characteristic that it can be
fully described in some approximation
okay so disregarding something which you
know we might we may change but in this
approximation
um the the history in this approximation
can be the same in the past and
different in the future
so this is why because of second places
dominate because they are
you can you run that last that last
claim by
real quick one more time i i didn't
quite catch i don't think it's like
i want to call agent in some in some
intermediate sense
yeah that's fine so we're talking about
the rover on mars and the claim was just
that
um as a system that has internal
internal
behaviors somehow which are on some
approximation so it's like it's a coarse
graining of the rover
into its causally relevant variables or
whatever
yeah in this approximation yeah uh
i have information about its dynamics i
can predict this dynamic
right but at some point my prediction uh
allows a splitting toward the future but
not over the past
yeah why no where where does that come
from i want to
claim that why is that
yeah that's my second paper not the one
on traces the one on agency
i want to claim that precisely uh
in this in a similar manner in which the
second law of thermodynamics
plus system separations plus um uh
long termization time naturally produces
traces
in exactly the same technique
this happens this kind of things happen
and and if you want to think how
um uh you know you have
you have microscopical degrees of
freedom that you don't know
but if they can act on macroscopic
degrees of freedom you don't know which
one
they're gonna happen so that's a
thermodynamic
description of us of a split of a micro
evolution in the future i said just just
really quick so
so david albrecht's story right
goes first i get records and then i
leverage leopards into an open future in
a closed past
you're not doing that you are you're
getting you're getting records and open
and open
let me rephrase that in david's story
you
first you get records um that gets you
um you know an open future and that
explains
the the asymmetry in my deliberative
capacities
you you just want to tell a similar
story that under that underpins them
independently is that is that right okay
yes and the reason i didn't get that
yesterday at all okay
the reason is exactly the one that you
were mentioning namely i i spent a long
time
telling myself look we have a record
therefore we can
we have the pastel the future open but
it doesn't work
i mean yeah and it's too weak for the
same reasons that you were saying i mean
we don't have full records if we had
full records perhaps this could work
but we don't fool a record so it's
exactly the same story i mean i don't
have a picture of hitler
young so does it mean that i can
deliberate about it no it
should be something else that uh
generates the systems that allows the
system that we call agents
and on what can be can it be granted
i mean if not from something extra
natural that comes in only on the second
law of thermodynamics
and i think that in my second paper i
tried i tried to model
that so deliberation is just one
particular ex
case deliberation is something that
happens
let me say one thing about deliberation
either
we can open up exactly the mechanism of
deliberation
i i can wake up exactly the mechanism
of my thermostat when it decides it okay
and then i realized that the time
orientation is fake
it doesn't really i mean it's really
time symmetric
or there's a deliberation and i treat it
as free okay
which i can because we always do it in
life
this is allowed by the second principle
dynamics not only is allowed
but is implemented at the second
principle dynamics precisely
because if you have system segregation
um
when energy goes from the hot to the
cold the the cold can have
macroscopic variables that that now
evolve differently
so this is a the information that goes
from entropy to
to microscopic so in other words i see
exactly the problems that you're
pointing out
and i think that a careful sort of
physicist discussion
of how is it possible that there are
this uh deciding systems
so what happened for real in in a
physical system
that we naturally describe as a decider
clarifies
that is nothing else that's standard
thermodynamics that indeed
um put the system in a
those systems are fetched that we
naturally describe them
as what happened inside them affect
affect the future and not the past
once the system exists the rest is
psychology
so of course now we are one of the
system and now we want to decide the
past and now we have
aims we have desires we have we have an
evolution we have information with
language but that's
that's once you have opened up the fact
that
there are systems that can determine the
future not the past
then you have to of course to to
understand how human beings
works is a much bigger problem
sure okay yeah no that's i that we need
to
love to see that the details of that i
just have to take a look at that paper
having a look at
but it i i you know while you were
talking i was uh
in fact not only agreeing with you but
recognizing the same
the same puzzling i i i i i went to i
had a lot of discussion with them
um with davey albert you were mentioning
and and uh and yes of course the
existence of the past
of traces is a major reason for us to
consider the future
um fixed but it's not sufficient as a
as a region for considering the
possibility that we can act on the
future in a sense so we need
we need to restart again from the second
principle dynamics and build and build
understanding that
so i agree with you so
at this point um you know i have this
quest maybe quite and i would like to
uh hear both of you so how do we
reconcile this with this whole idea of
the sum over histories
for going from so you can go from the
past to the present and the present to
the future
and in sort of feynman's idea of these
sort of you know sum over
all these possible histories i mean is
that
just then um a
natural way to um
to link i mean is time embedded in this
or is this just a way to marginalize
over you know probabilities to
distinguish it from sort of a
deterministic
path i mean this time is time intrinsic
to this so this is something
uh that i'm trying to understand um
but you know it may be a naive question
but i'd like to hear
your take on that you want to start eric
or should i
well so i mean when people ask whether
time is intrinsic that the
one just one thing one one wants to be
super clear about is do you mean
um do you mean the existence of the
ordering in other words this is the fact
that
it does the fact that time is a is a
parameter in
in in all of our physical theories is
that fundamental or do you mean
is the orientation of the past and the
future fundamental
right i think pretty clearly in carlo's
story
um it's a i don't know what his views on
this are but it's perfectly
comfortable with thinking that time in
the first sense
is is fundamental but not comfortable at
all with time
in the second sentence being fundamental
right
uh but yeah so that so you you were
asking about
were you asking about it in the first
sense or the second sentence for you
i guess i was asking about the first
sentence
yeah and because i mean
you know carlo has talked about theories
and theoretical ideas
in which time need not appear as a
parameter at all
right um
right but this is a uh yeah right so so
the two two separate questions one is a
question about the orientation
right let me say a word about that just
to
put it out of the way um the reason did
a discussion in quantum mechanics
uh but i i'm much convinced in fact i
just
just have a paper out of that um
in which uh that a discussion about
quantum and non-relativistic quantum
mechanics say uh
it just like the classical one it
doesn't change anything to what we've
been saying
so far maybe quantum mechanics is also
um
invariant in the time reversal
uh in fact i had a lot of discussions
with many various people and
with with uh uh uh they argentina we
wrote a very detailed people arguing
that and we got
three wonderful refugees report very
very
detailed with a lot of which basically
said all three but but we knew that
already
and and i agree in spite of some
discussion um i think that as far as the
orientation of time is concerned the
quantum mechanic does not change
anything
okay now the first the first issue is as
eric was saying
uh the the existence of a of a parameter
that all that that
uh in terms of which you you you uh
you order the the event of the uh
of the universe has not i haven't
touched
any of that in in in this discussion
uh at all and i think it's a
it's a separate issue uh because uh
when we talk about thermodynamics we're
always thinking
in a in a context in which we have a
time parameter
so um we learn from general relativity
that the world it's more complicated
than just a single time evolving
okay uh i mean you can one can use a
cosmological time and
logical time is an average in a sense
it's not them
um so it's definitely
when one goes to generativity and even
more what goes to quantum gravity
one needs a a wider notion of
temporality
uh which we we're not going into it now
and i am convinced that
we do not yet have a um clean
or even a vague in fact understanding
of thermodynamics in this wider context
so um in fact i consider one of the open
problems in
fundamental science we don't have we
really don't have a general relativistic
thermodynamics
not only in the quantum domain but even
in the classical domain we have
thermodynamics on a given curve
spacetime that was worked out by tolman
back in the 50s i guess um
but the thermodynamics in a fully
thermodynamic of spacetime so to say
uh it's it's still very much in the air
so uh asking questions about what is the
second law of dynamics what is entropy
when we fold in uh the
possibility of you know statistical
distribution of geometries
uh it's uh it's something which there's
very little clarity right now
in my head like and i think in many
people said
thank you
so uh but in a sense in a sense
uh it doesn't related because if if the
the the if
causation is fundamental which is the
the original thing
and if there's a fundamental arrow of
time
that the term is causing which is that
um
if it cannot be traced to uh
to just microscopic uh description
of things then we will be in trouble
to understand internativity i think to
understand quantum gravity because
we there we need even the
the vagus possibility of thinking
so um i just wanted to open up now and
uh peter morgan um did you want to
um ask your question i i can certainly
yeah if you can hear me that is i can
put
the comment i've put up here that is can
we use
um an analogy with transistors um
for which i the whole point is that you
have a control
input as well as the in and the out
uh any minimum stool and take it out
sorry no sorry this is some background
yeah
so um
it does feel as if often we try to
leverage
our position we think to ourselves oh
well if i do this then i can have a
million pounds in my bank account and
that's better than
doing some other action that will just
result in a dollar in our in our
bank account uh and so the very smallest
of
impulses in our brain results in a
really
relatively large change and so you're
always trying to leverage
uh and in some ways i mean there's the
the old sort of
uh uh
gnats and gnats and gnats and smaller
maps all the way down so to speak
uh but at least over a few scales um
so oh okay well
here i am hello
can i ask you you missed one word
because of the sound but it was a
keyword
you started by saying can we use analogy
with transistors
or transistors yes so with
three or three and really um
also in an analogy with leverage
leverage in the simple mechanical way
um just that we always are
um working to
to result in a bigger change as a result
of something small in
our minds typically in the beginning and
you have a sense of
an idea forming and then becoming a
motion of your muscles becoming emotion
of something else
uh so always getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and then some of those things
become actual traces
uh and some of them just disappear into
nothing
you think yourself i'm going to make a
big change by making this this
intervention and actually nothing
happens and other times you think to
yourself i'm going to make
almost no change by making this other
intervention of course and sometimes
that becomes something huge
um is the idea that somehow
this is this is this this ability to
cascade small into big is
is is uh is thermodynamic well in the
sense that
uh anything there there are flows of
energy
and of chemicals so uh there's not just
after all
thermodynamics is not just about energy
it's also about chemical potentials and
so on
uh and uh indeed one has different
chemical potential for every
every possible chemical there is uh
which
is enormous uh and so we
will leverage um something like a
particular
oil or a particular chemical so benzene
has a very different value in society
than
does uh chloroform or whatever it may be
and we seek to change the flows of all
these things separately
uh we try to separate the flow of
something that starts off as a mixture
of benzene and chloroform as part of
just fuel oil or whatever straight out
of the ground
uh we try to separate that out into cell
into different
by fractionation or whatever other
chemical or physical means
uh and always it's some engineer
somewhere has told themselves
hey if i just do this i can have this
huge great effect on the world
and my bank account is better because
but or for whatever motivation of course
i mean people
certainly don't want to say just dollars
uh but
at the same time resources of all
different kinds of
the dollar the abstract dollar in a way
it has its own chemical potential
something really quite complex
nonetheless is rooted in the real world
if not in gold
so sorry i've gone on
yes peter i i think i see what what
you're
you're at and i think i
i buy the analogy because uh uh
somehow what do you say you know we
study physics and we start everything
being linear so small things produce
small things
big things for big things and then of
course as soon as we go to more
complicated things we
discover that's not the way the world
work uh the work is not linear at
all um so they're big big
things that evolve into nothing and
there are a small thing
that has huge effect and then the
transistor is a
is based on this idea that you have one
one pin that determines with
the two big ones which one is uh uh
and and and and yes that's exactly the
point it seems to me so
um if you not only
think in terms of big and small but you
say you think that the big is what this
was what you did not control and
you did not know and and and
the big is what uh what you see
then you see a decider
uh something split in the future um
from a situation uh which of course the
the physics of a transistor is time
reversal environment obviously
but uh uh um
if you fold in dissipation um so
the the the little model that i had
about traces
it's like a transistor right because uh
i i had some macroscopic pendulum
interacting with the small little things
of which
i did not have control and once in a
while this is the point
um our intuition about thermodynamics is
always toward the
equilibrium or we say oh there's
non-equilibrium thermodynamics very
complicated but there's this
thing in between when you have system
separation
um and both systems want to go to
equilibrium but you know there is a long
long uh thermalization time and which is
a
part of the dominance to understand very
well and here it's exactly the same
situation because if the interaction is
a little rare once
a hot particle excites a a
a a a macroscopic pendulum
you have you have a small effect
creating something that enters into the
part that you call macroscopic
so for you have a trace and you can use
something similar
to model uh
uh deliberation okay
because you don't know what is happening
but you know the
the coming out of the of the result so
uh it is leverage
what in the sense that you were saying
that create traces uh
you know little little few photons into
the camera create a picture that allows
us to
know whether you know hitler exists or
not existed was in vienna or in berlin
so i i see the analogy and and and the
key point being that
is scale separation and
non-linearity and the big effect of
small causes
that ground all this phenomenology that
then we
um we interpret as
a as traces or agency
i don't know if one can do more than
this analogy can use that more
explicitly i don't know
great um thanks um
anyone else from the audience have any
questions
please feel free to type up in the chat
or
let me know and we can unmute and um
although i had i had one sort of minor
question
from yesterday yeah uh which was um
i was interested in your claim that uh
that all of aristotle's causes are uh
have the time to asymmetry that we that
we associate with our modern notion of
cause i thought that was a
somewhat surprising claim particularly
about uh final causes
why do you think final causes for
aristotle or
have the ordinary time orientation
because of that yeah it's good that you
raise that
um because my my first
my first uh thing and i'll tell you how
when i talked about that my first uh
train of thought was uh wait a minute
it's not true that uh
um that the cause precedes
the effect uh you know we use final
causes all the time you know i
i i mean he caused some final causes
because
precisely because he thinks that the the
thing at the end of the temporal chain
is the cause yeah i mean that's
aristotle
notion of common causes but it's it's
it's it's a notion that we use
it's not the notion that i mean he
emphasizes it you know i put
the cause for which uh uh you put money
in the bank is for the education of your
children
so the cause is in the future is the
education of your children
not because i take the umbrella is
because tomorrow is going to
rain so it's tomorrow's rain because of
my umbrella so we use the notion of
final causes all the time right
and then you say okay so therefore
causes are
uh not time-oriented and the final
causes are just a reversal
of uh efficient causes in in in in
aristotle language so efficient this is
when i was
uh the i i i put the cause in the past
and when i do the other way around it's
a final causes so it causes the future
but that's not true because final causes
are not the time reversal
of efficient causes at all there are
different beasts completely different
beasts
so therefore uh the the
the and like you know we we can go in
exactly what what
sort of means by castle because or what
we mean by cause of causes so in other
words
um both sufficient causes and the
uh final causes have
a time orientation they both require to
distinguish the past
and of course we usually can retrace the
fight that's what we usually do in our
mentality we would trace the
final causes into into efficient causes
you know
well we do that but of course aristotle
didn't aristotle final causes were
really fundamental causal building
blocks of the universe right
so aristotle thought there really was
causation from ends to beginnings which
we think
when you say oh you know when you say
the you know i put the money in my bank
account so as to send my children to
college
we can reconstruct that so that it's
really just efficient cause right it's
well you had the belief that
it's really just that you had the belief
that putting money in the bank would
you know and it's the belief that causes
the putting of money in not the
not the end but aristotle thought no
he be final causes really do bring about
states of affairs
oh yeah yeah yeah no yeah sure sure
yeah so what it was what i what i would
argue
is that you know from our understanding
of courses
yeah okay time no i i i i
yeah yeah you know um
final cause it's an aristotle very it's
it's really striking because it he was a
biologist as a scientist mostly and so
he basically
there's a page in his biology which i
find completely
striking he says look um you can
you can think of causation from the
future in biology
in evolutionary terms because i had been
in pedo class with
with his idea of of um essentially of
darwinian
um selection right the things
we have uh uh we have
the the cats have the right number of of
of
of legs because uh those without the
right number of legs die
because they cannot survive um and and
and aristotle has a as a very
interesting point he said
that's a great idea but it does not work
because we don't see cats born being
born with an arbitrary
number of legs like he talks about our
cows
uh if we if we saw that we would believe
that but no they already
are born but then he says but there are
seeds
so he's sort of suggesting it could
happen
that not the individual cats but the
entire
family of cats survives because of
natural selection so it's just there
and they say okay now you're gonna say
and he says well but i'm not
doing history here i'm doing the world
as it is
right to understand the world as it is
final causes
work right so it's aries he's almost
there he's almost there yeah
he's right here yes
yeah i think we have some questions in
the chat do you wanna yeah so i think uh
gary yeah yeah yes
um does your
theory imply a completely
determinate universe as the nozzle
believed
uh good um no the answer is no
um first of all um i hesitate
to to say what i presented as my theory
i i i i think i put a little couple of
uh pieces in in a puzzle
uh which is uh which is a number of
ideas
most of which are not mine um but but
but i try to
to then have an overall picture
including the the
the little i added and i
i i presented it uh in in the context of
classical mechanics mostly in which you
can think deterministically
but i think that that's obviously wrong
because uh
the world seems to be non-deterministic
uh with a lot of caret and the
appropriate sense
because of quantum mechanics
so the the present what we can know
about the present does not determine the
future
uh but i believe that nothing changes
and everything can be said
just with more complicated language
in terms of probabilities
at the same step i mean i talk about
hume and and
and uh um david lewis reformulating hume
causation in probabilistic terms i think
it can be done exactly the same thing
more in a more elaborated way
so there's no specific role for
determinism
in anything i said but of course is not
undeterminism of the future is
undetermined is equally toward the
future
or the past so it's not that by itself
undeterminism helps us
at all to understand um
the orientation of of of time
and and the nature of causation
okay
not everybody agrees with them with
these ideas because
some people think that quantum mechanics
is naturally
sort of uh
probability toward the future but i i i
don't see any evidence of that
quantum mechanics is a it's a it's it's
it's naturally interpreted in in in a
union senses it's a
regularity since the regularities are
not strict
are probabilistic but they are
regularities and if i look at this
irregularity there there their time
reversal
environment
thank you uh next we have tibor who has
a question
thank you um can you hear me yes yes
thank you excellent um two thoughts that
i've had prompted by
what you carlo and eric have been saying
uh one of them is it occurs to me that
quantum mechanics
may not be a theory on the
ultimately fundamental basic level on
that elementary scale it is itself a
theory perhaps
on some emergent scale and the world
being a complex system which i think we
all agree
uh means that
the uncertainties the unpredictabilities
the approximations that color was
talking about
arise as a result of the complexity of
this macroscopic scale
this sort of intermediate macroscopic
scale which is a quantum scale
rather than the world being
fundamentally
uh indeterministic so maybe it's
possible to accommodate the idea
that the world is deterministic at the
basic fundamental elementary scale but
it is indeterministic or at least
indeterminable
on some intermediate macroscopic scale
which is the quantum scale and then
there's another even greater scale which
is of course the scale where we live
now if that's the case um if that's
possible if that's a plausible idea
what i'd like to ask is is it impossible
to invoke the principle of least action
as a characterization of causation on
the elementary scale on that very lowest
bottom scale
where in a uh buridin and perhaps thomas
hobsian kind of
sense things happen because they can
interactions arise just because they
interact
the conservation laws hold and and
everything
seems to work down at that bottom scale
and
in a purely deterministic way and then
there's uh that there may be an ordering
by that whether there's a
a temporal direction or not i i don't
think that matters at that scale
all of that arises when we move to a
somewhat higher level
where we start talking about quantum
mechanics if we make that distinction if
we try and characterize quantum
mechanics as being emergent
as perhaps
i think is it stephen adler
at princeton who does that he thinks
that quantum mechanics is an emergent
system
um if we characterize it that way
does that help us to understand
causation at
different levels we have a causation at
the fundamental level which is just the
principle of least action
and we have a different notion of
causation in the quantum scale
uh let me tell you some precisely to the
various points first one the first point
you made is that
could quantum mechanics be um
uh a manifestation of an underlying
level where there is no under
undeterminism
the answer is yes absolutely and in fact
we know
not one but more than one theory where
uh that realizes that one is a pile of
weight
the broly bomb theory it's a perfectly
deterministic
sort of metaphysically classical theory
with equations of motions
and no indeterminism whatsoever
another ways of doing the same thing is
also
many world interpretation quantum
mechanics because that also
deterministic
it's just the schrodinger equation for
the real thing being the wave function
and then a more complicated story
connecting that to the observations of
um people don't like these options
not because they are incoherent
or wrong it's just because i don't like
these options
because uh because
they don't seem to teach us more than
what quantum mechanics teaches us
namely there is this invisible part of
the world
which we don't have access according to
the same theory we abs
is outside our reach uh we just cannot
know it
so de facto we have the still the same
impossibility to predict the past and
the future in in the many worlds because
we're in a branch and we don't know
about the other branches and so on and
so forth
we don't know which branch we are more
precise so
the first part is yes i mean we could
interpret a quantum mechanic this way
but then you say would that help us to
understand something about causation
better uh i don't think so because uh
the question that was being debated is
the time direction
of causation and all those theories
are time reversal invariant they don't
distinguish faster in the future
in the appropriate sense um so
we even if we take quantum mechanics and
put
and imagine that there is a actually
real whatever underlying level
level uh in which there is as you said
the principle of
list action working we're back to square
one
namely we have a time
reversal invariant fundamental
description of what happens
and no notion of causation time oriented
position
okay but that's i understand that
but i think it was eric who said that or
maybe you said it yesterday
that um the
time time directional
is itself an emerging property at the
bottom level
uh there is time reversal symmetry
yeah i agree there would be any law that
we made up
using the principle of least action at
the bottom level
would be time reversal symmetric
it's only at the emergent level when we
start getting feedback and more complex
systems that the the asymmetry emerges
so we can understand causation at the
time symmetric fundamental level
as just an implementation of
interactions of just one thing
happening after another one thing
causing another we can have causation
just as least actions and least
interactions
we can have causation at that level and
and causation would still be
describable using time symmetrical laws
perhaps even despite the fact that the
world itself is not time symmetric
it may be the case at the time there is
a fundamental
direction of time that there is a case
that where
in every interaction there's a before
and an after
and then it may be possible that that
exists
but it is described because it is
because all the actions are primitive
all the interactions are primitive
every interaction at that level is
describable using time symmetric laws
so maybe that our description of the
world can be type symmetrical as a law
and our physics can be time symmetrical
on that scale
and we can impose a time symmetrical
description on something which is
perhaps really time asymmetrical i don't
know
i don't think it makes a difference
whether the world is time symmetric or
time asymmetrical
and i'm talking about what the world
perhaps quote really
unquote is i'm talking about the
ontology here
it may be time masometric it may be time
symmetric
but we can describe both of these at
that fundamental level
with time symmetric laws because our
time symmetric laws cover
uh applying both directions it's like
the billiard balls on the table
you can just there is a case that
the balls were in one place and then you
play the game and the balls end up in
another place
and you could say there's a time
asymmetry about that
but at every interaction every collision
between two balls
you can describe it using time symmetric
laws
so i'm just wondering if it's not
possible for us to impose time
symmetry or to expect time symmetry
even perhaps when there isn't any
um i i think a philosopher should
should address this better than me but
let me add
as i said what would it mean to say
that there is a fundamental real
time asymmetry if we cannot describe it
we cannot perceive it we cannot observe
it we cannot
it's if it is invisible because
everything we
with experience about
uh or based time symmetric laws
so what what's the point of saying i
mean it wouldn't be like uh
yeah i mean everything is possible there
could be you know angels
dancing on dragons dragons in a parallel
universe is possible but
what's mine that's not what the world
we have access to that's true i i guess
for me the point is simply trying to
understand what i mean by causation
um assuming a time symmetric world
is no less visible it's no less
observable than a time asymmetric
one the world that you describe uh
and saying the world is fundamentally
time symmetrical well we can't observe
that either
so we don't gain anything from any of
these things other than
conceptually other than as a tool for
understanding what we're talking about
uh i think both of us all of us are
in theoretical physics we're all talking
about a world that no one can observe
we're looking for fundamental ways of
modeling the world
out of what we can produce theories that
that
that that derivative
uh uh where our models can predict or
describe the macroscopic world that we
experience
so look i mean there's a fundamental
sense of which the world is obviously
time asymmetric
right i mean it's as the song says
starts in a hot dense state
right and it's going to end in
anti-sitter space so
it's it and and it's it's fundamentally
asymmetric
in various features of our experience
right
but the question is just i take it the
question is just
um the puzzle arises
because uh at certain levels of
description
namely particularly the one the
microscopic ones that are relevant to
our experience
we see repeated patterns that are time
asymmetric
right there's a kind of it seems as
though there are
macroscopic laws that are themselves
time asymmetric
and the puzzle is how do you get
asymmetric laws
out of merely an asymmetric merely an
asymmetry in the initial conditions
there's manifestly any symmetry in the
initial conditions at every level of
description
right what's puzzling is that you can
leverage
right and this is what this is what's so
brilliant
and fascinating and would be
just wonderful if all the
details came together and i'm sort of
always on the fence about whether i
think it's happening or not
but what's up what would be amazing
right would be to be able to show that
this
one asymmetry merely in the initial
conditions
is then able to give rise to all of
these asymmetric
patterns not just not just that like the
past is different in the future of
course the passive in the future
but that it's different in this repeated
way that that under
that undergirds all of these seemingly
law-like asymmetric features
right that eggs never it's not just that
it's not just that there's you know more
broken eggs in the future than there are
in the past the eggs never unbreak
right how can that come from just an
asymmetry in the initial conditions
that seems like a magic trick um but
it's one that
people like carlo are are are trying to
try to pull off to show that it actually
can go
i think i think that's what's that's
what's going on here it's not about
whether
there is or isn't an asymmetry or
whatever it's about whether
any symmetry in nearly the initial
conditions
can give rise to all these beautiful
persistent
law-like pattern asymmetries
um in in the uh in the
in our ordinary experience right
so um i think we have a lot of questions
piling up in the chat so
i'd like us to move on to rory did you
want to ask your question please
yeah thanks so my questions about um
just uh just from the organizational
side of going into it so
leibniz in his uh discourse on
metaphysics um
makes an argument for a world where god
knows the future
and an argument that a kind of agency or
free will exists
and so in order to do that he makes a
distinction between
necessary truth which logically the
opposite is impossible um
and uh certain truths or certain events
and so certain events he says are
necessary x hypothesis which is after
they happen
um and so it's based on that he says
that
at at the moment in which we exist uh
the past
is made up of all necessary truths
because
they've their ex hypothesis that the
necessary truths
and the contingent uh certain truths are
now all necessary
but in the future uh among possibilities
there are
a limited number of possibilities
because of necessary truth which can be
otherwise
and then but then one one
way things will happen is certain um
because they can't happen more than one
way in his
uh organization so is that a good
is that a bad notion um or are there
what problems are there maybe with that
that framework and then also by that
empirical it's also an argument against
uh determinism in a way because looking
at the past and seeing a cost there's a
cost for every possible event
so it could be a different way and you
would also find a cause
so finding causes for the present
doesn't mean that the future
um can only go one way
um i don't um i haven't studied the
uh live mix on three wheels actually
uh and the distinction between uh
logical and certain
uh uh so
i
don't know i should think about that i
i'm possible because
of course the the problem obviously
comes in that period right spinoza is
debating with the same thing which are
completely different
um outcome um
but the problem is much older it has
been debated through the
european middle ages right god knows the
future
nobody questions that
so what does we mean we are free i mean
it's already in the mind of god what's
going to happen
next and that's exactly the problem it's
exactly the same problem of the
determinism so someone
tried to navigate out of that it seems
to me
that the specific um
solution that on which we
we reasonably work is one of spinozza
not the one of librates namely
we are confusing
levels of description in which we know
more and we know little
microphysics and macrophysics or in
spinoza uh
terminology uh we know what we wish but
we don't know the causes of what uh
uh because it's not in the sense we're
saying now the the causes of
that bring us to wish one thing or the
other thing to desire to decide one
thing and another thing
so um
the problem only comes if we
take the perfectly legitimate notion of
free will and decision
and and agency and arbitration
and deliberation which are all good ways
of describing the world
and we reinterpret them metaphysically
as denial to
a possible and forget quantum mechanics
a possible underlying
determinism and we shouldn't
it's like you know it's a it's a common
mistake that i think we do
constantly confuses our our our mind
like when we
uh i i i
prefer the way
uh metaphor for saying that when we
if we think the sunset is is is the sun
diving in the ocean when we discover
that santa stays there
uh and this earth spinning it doesn't
mean that there's no sunset anymore
there's still a sunset
it's just a sunset it's not what we
thought but but it has all the
properties
that we wanted before so if we discover
that this determinant in the world it
doesn't mean that there is no free will
it just means the free will is another
thing that what we thought before
i appreciate it um that sounds awesome
sorry sorry
great um so i guess the next question
we have from uh lee
yeah uh thank you thank you very much
for both of you
um so my question is how exactly we can
get the causal
asymmetry from the entropic asymmetry
i think the claim that we cannot
influence the past
is if it's true at all then would be
true as a matter of physical necessity
right it's not like we
it's terribly difficult to influence the
past but it's just
impossible to do so um if it's
if the claim is true at all but um
but the the entropic asymmetry
is is probabilistic in nature so i
wonder how this strict
um causal asymmetry could arise from the
probabilistic
statistical asymmetry the only way i can
make sense of this reductive
explanation for me is to think of um
causation as an epistemic sort of
notion i think eric mentioned this
briefly something close to this
um but uh you know so so changing the
past would amount to
changing our information about the past
or how what we believe about the past or
something like that
then it would be very difficult to do
change in the past but wouldn't be
impossible per se so is that the way we
should understand causation
uh as it is supposed to be reduced to
entropy um arrow or or
is there something else can i can i jump
out on this
yes sure yeah so so i think it's
important or i think it's important to
remember
the following thing here about causation
and about
agency and about changing the future and
changing the past
and i'm going to talk as if we live in a
perfectly ordinary classical world but i
don't think
quantum mechanics or relativity or
anything changes this
we cannot in the ordinary in the
ordinary physical sense
we cannot change either the past or the
future
right once the universe has its initial
conditions and it has its laws
it will evolve as it will evolve
right so the future is in that sense in
terms of like
in terms of the fundamental physical
description of the world the future is
just as fixed as the past okay
so when we talk about our ability to
change the future but our inability to
change the past we got to be quite
subtle about what we mean by that
we don't want to get it so it's exactly
like the sunset thing
right i mean there's still going to be a
sunset but it's not going to be what we
thought it was
in the for you know in the fourth
century or something like that it's
going to have to be something that
respects the fact
i mean at least if you're if you're at
all in if you're at all in any kind of
sympathy with the way i think about
the world it's going to have to respect
the fact that
um what what we're what's going on in
our minds when we think about
deliberating about how we want to bring
about changes in the future
has to be consistent with this is what
philosophers call compatibilism
has to be compatible with the
understanding that
um this is all this is all at the
microscopic level at the level of
physical law
this is all unfolding in a way that's
completely oblivious to my existence
and doesn't care one way to my about my
deliberations right
so um so it so it's so when we talk
about
when we talk about um you know the
inability to change the
past but the ability to change the
future
we we got to be really subtle about what
that exactly means
um and the best you know carlo might
have a slightly different way of
characterizing it than i do but
the way the way i like to think about it
is you've got to think about
what exactly is going on in deliberation
and about why it is that in deliberation
we we treat the future as open
right it's not it's not in any deep
sense that the future
really is more open at the past it's
that there's something about the nature
of our agency
that it makes sense to treat the future
as open
um and if you if you don't if you don't
i think characterize the problem
that way you're gonna give yourself fits
because you're gonna start thinking that
like well
gee what do you mean like is it you know
if you make it seem
unlikely that i could change the past
that seems wrong because it seems like
it's necessary
no you can't change the you know if
we're talking about
things in terms of what's what what are
necessary truths given physical law
can't change the future or the past one
iota right
if we're talking about if we're talking
about you know what underpins
um my when i deliberate that i
treat the future as open then the fact
that probabilism
that that's inherent in cisco comes into
it might seem less puzzling
than than you made it out to be when you
were when you were treating it as if
it's the past and the future
that are really uh can be influenced by
me in a deep you know metaphysical sense
or something like that
no a point very well taken there yeah
yeah this is very good that's a great
answer i think it's uh i
i i agree with each
okay can i try to add one one one thing
i'm trying to
um can i reformulate the question um
the second law of thermodynamics is not
an exact law
um it's a probabilistic law i mean
we we we can we can find a situation
where it is uh
uh and in fact we do find situations in
the laboratory
when we have a few number of things in
which we violate what we would think
the low thermodynamics would say if we
took it too seriously
and now the question is aha if we can
affect the future not the past because
of the second law of thermodynamics and
since the second automaker is
approximative
then the fact that we can affect the
future not the past is also proximity
so we might a little bit affect the past
as well that's the question
and i think eric answer is perfect no
when you
uh go to the regime where the second law
of thermodynamics does not hold
for instance a few number of degrees of
freedom is not that now you can affect
the past and also the future is that the
meaning
of affecting loses doesn't mean anything
anymore
the the meaning of i'm capable of
effectively
something that has meaning only um
in terms of notions where
uh uh uh where the second location holds
yeah thank you that was very clear thank
you yeah
so um i'll read out two comments before
we close with the final question so
sudha lakshmi has a comment about
people with schizophrenia are known to
have an abnormal sense of agency and
looking at their experiences
has been a very fruitful way to think
about the concept of agency itself
the main way in which their sense of
agency seems different from the standard
one
has to do with where to draw the line
between an agent and the rest of the
system
sort of partitioning the world right how
do you partition the world
and often people with schizophrenia
attribute the actions of other agents or
the behavior of the system itself
to themselves or the other way around so
it's kind of a partitioning
error if you will right so i
um and she's just wondering if people
have looked at
whether the sense of agency that people
with schizophrenia have
includes the notion of temporal
asymmetry
is there some clue to temporal asymmetry
there
uh because of this kind of partitioning
um
error and i thought it was a very
interesting comment and if you guys had
any
uh thoughts on it it would be wonderful
to hear
i mean that is super interesting it's
it's i mean a lot of
as i as i mean i think maybe this is a
this is this is a little bit of a
difference between me and carlo i really
do tend to think of these
of the of this of that third asymmetry
in terms of
our psychological properties right how
how we think about our agency
so yeah i think it'd be really
interesting to look at how other people
um
i suspect that i sus two things i sort
of mildly suspect that schizophrenics
don't have
um any differences in the in that with
respect to the temple asymmetry of the
notion of agency
i strongly suspect that even if they do
the literature hasn't noticed this
because it doesn't seem like the kind of
thing that
the relevant people would pay attention
to but i don't know
yeah so uh there's another thank you
there's another comment
uh which is from fardos um who is a
friend of mine
and he said you know he's kind of
curious why we have not touched on
can't at all and we have discussed hume
spinoza aristotle well the entire
pantheon really and leibniz
but not can't and you know the synthetic
april right judgments um
and so they're just in your head they're
not in the world
so right yes
why would we if you want to know what
the origin of the causal asymmetry has a
for con
that's we impose it that way yeah
carlo do you want to step in and say
something or um i can then move
no i mean let me say something a bit
naive
uh of course you can be a kantian and of
course it's fine and of course
but then um we are naturalists so the
the
the my head in which the the priori are
sitting
we want to i mean it's just this form
superior of knowledge we want to re
reinterpret them as actual
natural um
the subject it's part of nature
in my philosophy so it's fine can't but
it's just the half of the story i want
to know the other half of the story
yeah it's not the big story right yes so
uh okay so
i think we should uh since it's getting
on we'll close with the final question
from cecilia and her question is
hypothetically let's say the past at the
macro scale
can change in accordance with the new
future chosen by an
agent from within the present moment
like the light cone model
and say this new correlation was an
unconscious
choice by said agent then records of its
previous past would exist as memories
perhaps traces also exist in three
dimensions as evidence
seeing as the agent is as carlo believes
part of nature
nature would thus grant the agent's
conscious choice to hold their memories
as true
while also granting its unconscious
choice for a new past or future
correlation
would this harmonious system grant both
of the agents requests
or would there be a dilemma what could
appear in the present moment to
fulfill its desire while staying within
the agent's realm
of uh expectation
interesting hypothetical uh i don't know
it's too complicated
but it's a it could be a novel right
it's a scientific novel of this story i
i i don't know i i'm not capable to
answer i don't know very clear that
you follow the story in detail
okay so great uh i guess we
uh wrap up here thank you eric and carlo
for a wonderful discussion
and uh for engaging this very sort of
subtle nuanced complicated material and
clarifying things for us
and um um and thank you to everyone who
attended
and uh for all their wonderful questions
so very very delighted and we hope that
you will all participate in this
continuing series
and i just want to mention that the
recording of yesterday's talk and
today's
conversation will both be available
within a week
so um if you want to listen to it again
or pass the word and share it
please do so thank you once again
eric and carlo for sharing this uh
saturday afternoon
with us thanks for having us yeah that
was that was that was a total treat
really looking forward to this uh
continuing with thank you
throughout you know interesting for me
thank you eric i think i
i'm gonna meditate on the points that
you raised especially the
the the the relevance of the complexity
of the higher level
of the agency uh role um
and um so i look forward for the
continuation of discussion also
thank you thanks everyone bye have a
lovely rest of the weekend
ciao